you were so good as Adam Moore like you
know this movie is wonderful but there
are some heartbreaking moments and you
are the comedic relief I needed so thank
you oh thank you I appreciate that you
know I've interviewed actors of the
years and when I asked me you know what
would be a bucket list role for them so
many people say I'd love to play a
superhero I'd love to get into the MCU
were you that kind of person or did this
phone call from James Gunn kind of come
out of nowhere
it's really interesting I mean I I
auditioned over like a number a number
of months and um was really really
grateful to eventually get that that
phone call but in in a way this is like
the bucket list role that I didn't even
realize was on my bucket list and so you
know I got it you know what I mean and
retrospectively I'm reflecting on it and
thinking just how how lucky I am and uh
how much it's kind of you know enriched
my appreciation of both comedy and drama
because I got to you know do a bit of
both in this movie and I'm such a fan of
the Guardians that to be in it uh just
feels crazy and it's still kind of
seeping in to be honest
I can only imagine you know you talk
about
this cast was for you you talk about
Chris Pratt and how giving he was and
the advice that he gave you what would
you say is the best piece of advice he
gave you while you were filming
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3.
you know honestly there's a list as long
as my arm uh of things that Chris kind
of passed on to me and I'm really really
grateful for that I think
um you know Chris has kind of Taken on a
lot of responsibility you know with
these with these movies naturally and
and as you know the lead of these films
he's
he's had to
um shoulder just a lot of pressure and
uh you know a huge workload and he's
he's done it with such Grace and
humility and all the while making
newcomers and the people around him feel
welcome and I just admire that so much
you know I I think truthfully the things
that you pass on to me I'll probably
just kind of keep like closer to my to
my chest
um but uh I I massively appreciate him
and it certainly you know made me think
that if ever I'm if ever I'm in a
position where I'm at that stage in my
career or I was lucky to be halfway
there and uh you know a young actor came
onto my set I'd want to treat them in
the same way yeah oh I love hearing that
uh because he seems that way so it's
nice to hear that he's actually like
that in real life as well
um you know
I I know this is the third film this is
kind of the end of the trilogy for James
Gunn's you know Guardians of the Galaxy
but when it comes to Adam Warlock and
the future in the MCU if you were Kevin
feige you can make all the decisions
what would you love to see Adam Warlock
do in the MCU
oh
why was Kevin feige
everyone's there to play that game right
just like
um what an amazing do you want more of
him do you want to do more movies I
would I would love to I would love to to
uh continue to kind of uh evolve Adam um
that would be that would be a real
genuine honor um and it's obviously not
for me to say how or or or you know uh
when that would happen but um I I have
ultimate faith in in Kevin and then Lou
and Marvel and and everybody who is you
know uh empowered to make that decision
does it feel like where The Millers came
out 10 years ago
it's crazy yeah where The Millers came
out 10 years ago um wild I remember
that's how I first discovered you oh wow
wow yeah that's that's a long time ago
and uh yeah kind of early early moment
in my career that I'm I'm still very
very grateful for what's some of your
favorite memories from working on that
set
um I think my mom coming out to visit me
in uh Wilmington North Carolina uh me
and my mum tried Fried Green Tomatoes
tomatoes
tomatoes and uh and she uh took off all
the batter and ate the green tomato out
of the batter and I was like mum that's
not okay that's kind of you wait but but
bless her she she loves Tomatoes as they
are so hats off to hats off to her okay
so what does your mom think of you being
a part of the MCU
she's very excited for me she also wants
me to take rocket home
um I've explained that I can't kidnap
Bradley Cooper that's not something I
can do but uh have you tried that's true
listen exactly you've got to try for I
haven't even tried I haven't even tried
do it for your mom okay yeah what kind
of son am I haven't even given it a shot
yet you're right you're right that's
defeatist I'd support it I'm just saying
I think Bradley would too
must come move to London I'll ask him
I'll ask him great
movie you're um such a standout so I
can't wait to see what else you do it's
very kind thank you so much
and mantis was such a standout in volume
three for me I just I fell in love with
her all over again I loved it so much
oh thank you so much
um we know that Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 is the third and final film in
James Gunn's version of Guardians of the
Galaxy did you feel moments of
Bittersweet on set
yeah of course I mean we had so much fun
shooting the movie but
um this movie is has a darker tone of
course so you know we we had to tap into
like very deep and sad emotions as well
um
yeah
but it's this one is it feels very
special because you get to learn more
about Rocket's backstory too
and and knowing that this is the last
time that we're gonna see all these
Guardians together I mean this might not
be the end of guardians but did did you
feel that weight as well
yeah towards the end of the movie we
shot
um a scene with the Guardians of the
Galaxy and it felt like
an ending of some sort you know so the
emotions were real
yeah you could you could feel that too
is there anything you can tell us about
the future of mantis and the Guardians
I've I have no clue
I have no clue what's gonna happen
um to mentes like I I don't know I I
love playing the character
um you know it's hard to say goodbye but
I don't know I don't know what's gonna
happen
would you be open to playing mantis
again if the opportunity were to present
itself
I mean maybe but it would need to be the
right project the right script and and
it's a it's a it's a tough one because
for me mantis is so connected with James
Gunn and we created the character
together and you know each word that
meant is said was either it was written
by James Gunn and even if it was a
project a movie that was directed by
someone else it was always supervised by
him you know to make sure that the
characters were still like making sense
um like with his vision you know so I
don't know what's gonna happen yeah no
that makes complete sense to me how did
you say that not just your life and
meeting these people but just
career-wise how has being part of the
Guardians of the Galaxy changed your
life
oh it changed my life completely of
course
um back then when I got cast in the
movie it was very hard for me to get
roles too and people would tell me I was
too different and hard to cast and or
they would say that if I can't do a
perfect American accent I'm not going to
be able to work in Hollywood and back
then it would be like almost like the
most important thing you know and since
then it changed so much and there's like
other characters that happen to have a
foreign accent I mean like what foreign
means anyway you know it depends on
which country you're talking to like you
know
um yeah so now it's different but yeah
well you go from playing this lovable
empath one of the biggest franchises
ever to now playing a villain in another
massive franchise
um what's the best part about playing a
villain in a Tom Cruise movie
um no it's uh it's fun to um it's I mean
for me it's more like the it's it's it's
I feel very grateful to be working with
such incredible directors who who are
such uh Visionary uh you know
people and and yeah of course working
with Incredible people like amazing
people like Tom Cruise yeah I feel very
very grateful for sure and not wait to
see this character well thank you so
much and uh yeah so much exciting things
going on for you right now thank you
thank you